[Música]
la migración en el 2013
con los 810 iago nació en el 2015
3 kilos
una tarde que iba sola con ellos rumbo a
la casa había una tormenta muy fuerte la
de donde íbamos caminando avanzando en
auto estaba inundada pero yo la mamá
superpuesta sentía la seguridad de pasar
esa calle pues no a la mitad empezó a
subir el nivel del agua y me dio un
terror que se metiera el agua el motor
entonces lo único que hice fue orillar
me a esperar que pasa la torna en lo que
recorría una hora y media entre cantos
risas juegos para que no se calmara
empecé a observar lo que empezó a pasar
en esa calle inundada
y lo que me di cuenta es que era mucha
basura muchísima basura llegue a casa
enojada que no tenía ciudad
en nuestras calles
y empecé a echar culpas mi primer error
mi segundo y grave error fue creer que
yo era una víctima de esto
porque grave error porque en realidad
nosotros causamos esto este es un muy
conocido es porque muchos los presentes
de aquí sepan de que el lugar hablando y
esto es responsabilidad y resultado de
cada uno de los que estamos aquí incluso
de los que visitamos esta ciudad porque
venimos como foráneos y dejamos residuos
dejamos nuestra basura
cuando inicie la asociación civil me
costó mucho trabajo porque desconocía
del tema que fue lo que hice me capacité
cada proyecto que inicie debe de estar
basado en educación en capacitación
siempre acercarse a personas preparadas
en el tema que ustedes quieren emprender
les decía quién es el responsable
todos todos somos responsables no
importa qué edad tengas no importa que
te dediques no importa si vas en kínder
primaria universidad si estás jubilado
todos somos responsables de la basura
que se genera en nuestra ciudad podemos
evitar estas situaciones una de las
tantas como la paz o tania si si podemos
y ahí fue donde me hice la pregunta
tania tú puedes hacer algo por tu ciudad
no pues no sé claro que si puedes y así
como yo lo pueden hacer ustedes pero
como de seguro tengo que viajar a otros
países para salvar a los osos a las
focas no podemos hacer todos algo desde
aquí desde su casa desde su escuela
desde su trabajo
y esto es lo principal la educación
educación ambiental que nosotros
brindamos en kínder primaria secundaria
preparatoria doctorados empresas
industria hogares comercios la tiendita
de la esquina
iglesias nosotros vamos y les decimos
que hacer porque así como tania se
sintió atrapada en una situación y se
sintió después responsable y con ganas
de ayudar mucha gente en la región se
está sumando quiere hacer algo pero no
sabe cómo no sabe a dónde aquí está la
solución hay que educarnos
el primer punto es la separación desde
la fuente inicial en esta etapa créanme
que incluso yo me he topado con que soy
con un bote de yogur y dejo un poquito y
me paro en los botes orgánicos e
inorgánicos y digo dónde va
donde lo tiro como lo tiro
me pongo a investigar y salió la
solución si no me voy a beber todo el
líquido lo tengo que vaciar y entonces
es un residuo inorgánico así de fácil
créanme que es muy sencillo más sencillo
de lo que parece nos complican luego las
cosas y creemos que yo no puedo hacer
eso ay no qué flojera es mucho trabajo
no que lo hagan los demás no hay que
hacerse responsable de nuestros residuos
de nuestros actos
el siguiente punto en el que trabajamos
nosotros es en las actividades en
beneficios de todos el beneficio es para
todos no nada más para tania y su
agrupación es para todos cuando nosotros
limpiamos un lago un arroyo un manglar
no es mi casa es la casa de todos es el
hogar de todos ahí nos juntamos
fusionamos diversas asociaciones
agrupaciones cada una dirigida a un tema
totalmente diferentes pero todos
preocupados por nuestro único hogar y no
estamos hablando de que viajamos al otro
lado del mundo empezamos por nuestra
comunidad
esta es una limpieza de colonia
mi mamá cuando vio esta foto me dijo
como de chica te tenía que andar
presionando para que me ayudarás y ahora
mira te lo dije bueno mamá ya crecí ya
madurez lo curioso de esta foto quiero
que vean a la señora que tiene la escoba
azul
cuando yo me acerqué con mi compañera a
limpiar esa área yo vi esa señora con
tanta seguridad que yo dije es la dueña
de la casa
terminamos de lavar barre de recoger los
residuos y mi sorpresa fue que me dijo
gracias licenciada por venir a ayudarnos
dije así cuando usted necesite ayuda le
podemos informar la separación correcta
para que lo implemente en su casa y me
dice sí solo que yo no vivo aquí yo vivo
enfrente y yo me quedé como misses y yo
soy la vecina y entendí esa frase de no
es mi basura pero es mi planeta no era
su basura pero era su calle era su
vecino le afectaba y esa elección de las
personas que no tienen educación
y me quedé voy por el camino correcto
implementamos reciclatón es cuando
ustedes empiezan a separar sus residuos
y no saben qué hacer con ellos y les
estorban porque ahí tengo mi casa llena
de basura que son residuos separados no
se preocupen de verdad hay muchísimas
agrupaciones que cada mes o cada 15 días
reciben esos residuos y esos residuos
logran ser reciclados logran tener un
tratamiento correcto las calles
inundadas se dan principalmente por el
aceite quemado que muchas veces en casa
tiramos en la tarea sin saber la
consecuencia toda acción tiene una
consecuencia ese aceite mezclado con
agua de detergentes suavizantes y
líquidos de comida
forma esa masa pegajosa
y crear el tapón para que se tape una
avenida
las reforestaciones
aquí hay algo muy curioso porque cuando
decimos que vamos a reforestar un parque
se ve muy bonita la foto que nos tomamos
todos a la hora de poner el árbol y
nunca más nos volvemos a aparecer en ese
árbol cierto no
bueno pues aquí lo que hacemos es si
cada uno va a sumarse a la reforestación
tiene que comprometerse a que mínimo dos
veces a la semana tiene que ir al lugar
a regar lo mínimo y se va evaluando cómo
va creciendo esa planta también hacemos
reforestación en la sierra tal vez
ustedes no lo sepan pero hay muchas
agrupaciones que trabajan en la sierra
porque nos estamos quedando sin agua de
verdad necesitan reforestar esa zona y
es un viaje para llegar hasta allá
increíble pero aún así nos sumamos más
de 80 personas diferentes empresas
agrupaciones y logramos llegar y todos
con el mismo objetivo la energía las
pilas de poder ayudar eramos 80 y los
beneficiados son millones
estas imágenes a mi me impactan mucho
cuando inicie con valentina y thiago
pensé que les voy a dejar a mis hijos
que van a vivir ellos pero esa fue mi
motivación mi momento de despertar de
reaccionar no tienen por qué tener dos
bebés para poder ser conscientes de lo
que están haciendo ustedes pueden
decidir hoy pueden decidir ahora son la
generación que nos puede salvar o nos
puede hundir un poquito más
si ustedes ven estas imágenes es
irresponsabilidad de algún ser humano no
de tania
sin embargo también trabajamos para
ellos porque si respetamos la vida de
ellos respetamos la vida de una planta
nos respetamos a nosotros mismos nuestro
ambiente va a ser completamente
diferente tanto en valores cultura
necesitamos crear conciencia en base al
respeto del que está al lado del que
está abajo así de importante es el pasto
así de importante es el árbol así de
importante es la familia así de
importante es respetar los objetos y
cosas que no son de nosotros
por eso es que les doy la opción si
ustedes quieren ser parte de la solución
o del problema
gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]